[Music]
i love stainless steel nails because i
hate it when i'm at a dinner party and i
spill wine on my favorite nails
now they're all stained so this is a
2014 freightliner mercedes-benz engine
224 000 miles on it which is a lot of
miles but they maintained it it's really
clean in there yeah bro
does that not look baller
oh god a bunch of tourists are coming um
but this is like the sliding door
situation
i got some a-scoot lights recessed
it's like in there
[Music]
there's some spam
i'm gonna be eating some of this later
i live right here in a van because it's
right next to the creek in the cave the
most happening comedy spot in new york
it's like an unspoken agreement they let
me get water and charge my [ __ ] there
but they're kind of like
what the [ __ ] man that's why i park here
because there's always a mic and there's
never not an excuse to it's like going
to my living room to do a set
and if it's that accessible you're gonna
get better than everyone else and you
know a competitive edge give myself the
best opportunity to succeed and i've
done that by uh making myself mobile and
picking this spot to live in at times
for i lived with my mom for four years
in seattle doing comedy so i got used to
not working i got spoiled so i was like
let me have more of that i was
separatist before i moved into the van
and the van helped me it's like a
continuous cycle i am separatist so i do
separatist activities and just
activities make me more apart from
society but i think this is just who i
am to a degree hey just finished putting
in the walls
and put in the lights
and the fan
recess and it was a pain in the ass and
i'm tired as [ __ ] took uh let's see
about 24 hours
to get all this done
and this [ __ ] shoddy quality
so
uh
hoping that other projects will be
easier and s4 but uh it's good to get it
all out of the way now i'm gonna
probably take a shower
and eat
my fingernails and
be a human again
get out of this home depot parking lot
maybe
live my life this is some uh
more food it's got a bunch of food
from this person on craigslist
she sold me a mta card for a hundred and
five dollars and then she just gave me a
bunch of free [ __ ] so that was a good
successful craigslist meeting you know i
don't want to just be a road comic i
would love to be a road comic but i want
to be remembered i want to make good
stuff and we all do that's why we do
this i want to have an interesting
viewpoint
oh my god
this is stupid
so hot in here
let me turn on the fan to [ __ ]
two it goes to three but we're not there
yet
air conditioning
running water
is what i miss about home life i like
not having garbage trucks drive right by
your head when you're trying to sleep i
think that'd be nice that's my pee
bottle you're standing next to i'm very
uh confrontational sometimes just um
just pretend like it was sitting like
right next to the trash can
no okay cool cool
because then people are going to be like
you sleep with your pee by your feet
it's got me into a van and not getting
booked it's clean bro so all right so
yeah tell me why you want the white lid
then why lid for your white hog i just
have this whole attitude of uh i don't
give a [ __ ] about you man because if you
have like a small you got to like
[ __ ] put it right on the head of your
dick and that's uncomfortable no one
wants like sharp objects right by the
tip of your dick
what kind of life is that oh god we're
out of three guys
it's happening this is kimchi it's kind
of
a lot it's been through a lot
how often do you do comedy every day
probably three or four sets a night i've
been working on the car recently so i've
been lazy feel guilty about that
the benefits include you get to pay zero
dollars in rent to live in upper east
side so you're getting the most bang for
your buck in new york the girls are
fascinated by your life they want a
piece of that artist action you know